what did we do last time under the
calculus of trig functions I think if I
remember right we established what all
of the derivatives were remember that so
let's see how well we can remember them
we'll start with the basics the board we
always start with this silence to do
this pause what the words the derivative
cos is negative sine the derivative of
tan ends up here they're more
complicated it's a question it's set
square I can't now this will be a little
trickier let's see if we can remember
the reciprocal functions let's do I
think it has a cosec in it as well
what's the function that goes with it
I think it's caught now by the way one
of the rate ways you can remember why
you started your son what always you can
remember that it's not going to be
saico-tek tan is because cosec is 1 over
son but this is sign a record so if
there were a tan there they would they
would cancel out wouldn't they
so that's taking very Kristin Klock pair
up in the same way if we do say what do
we get follow the pattern
sit and last one
I think it's negative cosine squared you
can go ahead and check your table and
see if we remembered right okay great
fantastic now these are all just to you
know we said that the rules shortcuts
things that are trying to give you
insights about these graphs right so we
do need to remember them particularly
B's these ought to become kind of
reflexes for you eventually right but
then the question is how do you use them
or in what cases can you use them what
kinds of applications are there was a
few main ones okay for instance there's
graphing okay we'll be doing some of the
graphing now that we know how to
differentiate trig function
we can know where important features
like stationary points and points
inflection we can know where they are
even if you don't get something nice and
neat like these these you know where the
features are you know there's gotta be
stationary points it PI on two and three
planets you and you know the points of
inflection and so and so on right but if
I were to say change it a little bit
like say this you'd be like I'm sure it
has stationary voice but don't know
exactly where they are but of course now
we have calculus we can determine them
with great accuracy okay so Kranthi what
else might you use calculus if she
functions for and I think what kinds of
problems all we can get apart from just
differentiate wait might you need to use
the derivative for something tell you
okay now vexing questions that happen we
treat someone can be quite tricky you
have to be careful when you're doing
these because when you've got a trig
function right what kind of what that
looks like it's this kind of thing okay
so the whole idea of a maximum there or
there there's it only going to be just
one you're always gonna get a series
often right but almost certainly like
what kinds of shapes do trig functions
turn up in its treat right you expect
them in triangles yeah so for instance a
really a classic example is we might
give you say and isosceles triangle and
say it's inscribed inside a circle okay
and we would say this has been posed
many many times what's the maximum area
or what might be the side lengths for
the maximum area of this some of this
triangle we did the circle or maybe I
should say what should the angle sizes
be to be to get the maximum mario's
now it turns out that you want to be
glad for pretty sure anyway okay but how
would you go about that you use you find
your areas in terms of this you'd be
like haha Sweden sorry off every sexy
and so on okay but obviously not all of
these values apply to this particular
situation
do they so you find a whole bunch of
stationary points but only some of them
important to you probably the cute ones
in business anyway you get the idea
there's going to be restrictions applied
on this that you have to be very careful
for now I just want to have a look at
one particular question if you're near
in 14h let's have a look at our cushion
seats
so if you have a look there's a whole
bunch of pots to question seeks
essentially this is what they want they
give you his paragraphs or his pair of
boxers get you one that they say tell me
what the features are stationary points
points in flexure and then draw it for
me okay now let's just give this to go
down off the face of it
what would you do first so what's the
degree but we just need clothes goes to
negative sign and route three side
actually become so clear the most
important features that you initially
want are stationary points okay so I
would say the derivative is equal to
zero for stationary points in other
words okay so can we go ahead and solve
this thing what would you do
take a side the other side okay now what
I could find my cause and you can solve
that couldn't you that'd be fine I think
from memory if you have a look at this
petite question no troubles come up when
you do this however be careful
you can't just divide by things right
even though it's pretty legit why not /
think inclusion problem you're trying to
solve an equation what kind of problems
can be introduced you eliminate
solutions when you divide okay when you
divide you live in a decisions how so
later on we might have dogs which is
that what we do potentially so I would
add more solutions that you have to
check which might not be valid because
if this eliminate solutions what might
introduce additional ones things like
squaring right and multiplying by other
things you know if I had a reciprocal
key so
and then I multiply through you're
increasing the order of the equation
sawed off okay it's not a polynomial but
you get the same idea okay so just be
careful how I note that what kind of
restriction does this actually add all
my solutions so if I divide by cos x cos
x copy zero right right now in the
domain that I'm interested in if they
actually give us a domain
later on they use it to me
where does cos x equals zero within
those values it's a pile too and as it
happens I think it'd be fine with that
but just watch out what if we're not 10x
equals root 3 hmm what's that gonna be
equal to I don't see it
yeah I'm between tripod three I'm
between don't you cry more to class io2
expect another one right where's the
other one
10 is just periodic every Pyrates isn't
it actually Jamie if I added another PI
obviously I be 7.3 which is outside okay
happy what else do I need to do with
this
I've on I've determined through
stationary points okay what else they
asked of us we're gonna need to
determine the nature right particularly
being that these two of them okay so
we've got two ways to determine the
nature of stationary point what are the
two ways I could use the first remove
right and then you drew draw a table and
you do your neighborhood test that's
right
alternatively I could now just you have
a look at it which do you tend toward
which do you think would be simpler I'm
hearing but this is interesting
um he is the first derivative right what
would the second derivative be
can I can I give you an interesting idea
it's not a calculator or anything like
that but I'm pretty sure it's equal to
isn't it isn't it cuz that's what sine
and cos do right you differentiate them
and they turn around in quitting your
science you differentiate again and both
of them will be pretty sure you'll get
up well here we go you get negative cos
negative which is bad I don't know we
kind of need to work out what the Y
values are anyway so I kind of tend
towards the second derivative well it
doesn't matter let's evaluate them
anyway so I think half of you have
actually been saying to me let's do the
first roof so let's just test it out
okay know what value shall I test now
let me just put a white caution here
okay um one of the nice things about
knowing that we've got a trig function
of these particular tree functions is we
know this continuity all the way through
okay so in some senses it won't matter
all that much being that number one I
know we're both stationary points are
and number two there are no breaks in
the graph I can be quite far away from
my station if I still get a reliable
result I know okay so for instance I
could say zero I couldn't say part of me
between them and I could say surprise
because all of those they do go in order
and that's fine okay can anyone tell me
why in other circumstances these
particular values that are chosen might
not be such a good idea
any ideas there they're pretty far away
remember the whole graph how wide is the
whole thing the interest the domain of
interested in it's a it's only like six
and a bit units all the way across okay
six a bit radians okay now contemplate
the difference between some of these
like from here to here and that's
actually quite a gap like when you do
the graph okay so I would generally say
these are actually probably too far if I
if I didn't have a graph that I'm used
so much of that and then I already have
both stationary points pilot three what
is that I guess it's one point 0.05 or
144 something like that right so better
values would be like saying one and one
point one like they have really closer
you can know exactly if you're going
positive and then negative that's going
to be a maximum right whereas usually
that's too far away it doesn't tend to
be server level but anyway I think you
really make a key but I'm just issuing
the question well values do we get I'm
Pete zero plan G fine
because they're very easy to about it
for the first reading baby let's try
zero times zero is zero the cause of
zero is 1 this is just gonna be okay
with that sine of pi is also 0 cos of PI
is negative 1
okay keep by the way like I literally
tracing that out in my head I'm thinking
about that if you don't feel comfortable
yet about you know graphing that kind of
thing when you can do that in your head
you need to grapple so that it gets in
there okay so we said that's a good
negative 1 which is negative okay and a
2pi sine is 0 again and cause the way
back to 1 okay so we've got positive
okay so now I have the nature all right
great I've done that is there anything
else I need any other important features
they actually do a survey they want
points inflection a pretty sure okay so
here's my second derivative
okay now there's another handy feature
that tree graphs have which is that
remember how we said there's so much
symmetry to a tree graph all over in
like all these different kinds of
directions okay
so therefore in this particular example
I actually don't need to do all that
much way to find a way that point
inflection ah do I
because if I know where the stationary
points are where would you expect the
points of inflection to be right halfway
between them right so to take the
average of those that's 1 plus 1 over 2
that's gonna be 5 PI on 6 5 plan seems
so 4 points of inflection isn't anyone
at 5 miles what so what's the gap from
here to here once again it's pi so
therefore I went from here to sorry I
should say stationary point at pylon 3
I've just said there's a point of
inflection at final client on seeks then
there's another stationary point pass
what I say 4.3 okay so from here to here
that's PI on to here to here that's
prime to where would you expect the
point of inflection to be after that I
am to further my still inside the domain
nice don't side the domain this is um
this is 8 PI on 6 and this is what's
this this is 3 5 6 so when I add them I
get 11 pilot 6 which is still the domain
pretty sure am I done my numbers right
yeah
okay are you gonna expect on over here
we're at pilot three and if you go back
pile to which ones bigger high on two is
bigger so you're going to go past the
origin so you're not going to get what
over here okay there you go
one two three four I think you can graph
it from there okay